welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and Loki season 2 is now in the
endgame with all of time space and
reality apparently obliterated by the
failure of the Loom following the
spaghettification of Victor timley or as
Twitter is now hilariously calling him
he who L Mains well done Twitter that
was a good one but this can't be the end
right headwriter Eric Martin is
promising that episodes 5 and six are
the best of this series and we have
definitely seen trailer shots of moments
that we have yet to see in season 2 of
Loki also we just got a new mid-season
trailer with several new shots and clips
from episodes 5 and six got to break
that down so in this video I'm going to
break down all of these remaining bits
of footage to dig saww them together
into what's in store for the final
chapters of this season and I have
realized that we are finally going to
see all of these varant Origins
including ob's origin as the tva's true
founder I believe I found the evidence
and since OB seems to be the key to
everything join us in celebrating this
apocalyptic Moment by grabbing one of
these OB inspired we're all going to die
shirts from nerd riot. shop so on Victor
timely turning into angel hair the
temporal Loom has exploded sending a
wall of fiery temporal radiation to
consume the TVA apparently spelling out
the Doom for all of known realities but
as I explained in Saturday's video this
might actually be a good thing like the
bursting of a dam releasing floodwaters
destructive yes but restoring nature to
its natural state of chaotic entropy and
that reality is meant to be a messy
Multiverse and that's okay but we know
from Trailer footage that Loki will try
to get out of this the likeliest path is
time slipping because Loki is definitely
not finished time slipping on this
season trailer footage shows some time
slipping in several more instances back
through moments and locations of the
first four episodes of season 2 in other
parts of the TVA into a chrona monitor
Bay to see another version of Loki
flipping through the TVA handbook in and
out of time theater number five some
other location with these metal pipes
the Brockton Oklahoma McDonald's parking
lot and to the parking lot of a piranha
Powersports where we will see M's origin
as a jet ski salesman more on that in a
bit there will be other key moments that
Loki will revisit via time slipping I'll
get to those but his Target will be
right before the temporal meltdown trer
footage shows Loki back in the loom
observation deck saying things that he
didn't say when he was there in episode
4 like asking OB this what could we have
done differently and in other promo
shots we hear him saying the word again
again as if we are going to see them try
something new to prevent this meltdown
again we also see this full teamup shot
of Loki speaking into a microphone in
this room all right we did not see this
before making me think that we're going
to see it in one of these upcoming
episodes I mean look having analyzed
trailer editing and marketing tactics
for several years now I can tell you
this might be a shot film solely for the
trailers and we might not see it in the
show but I really think in this moment
right here when Loki has a microphone he
may be directing another version of Loki
who time slipped back to right before
the Meltdown and that Loki decided to
walk out into the core himself because
other trailer shots show Loki trudging
out onto that gang way alone no
protective gear now since the magical
barriers of the TVA were dropped with
the reboot of Miss minutes he may be
using some kind of magical charm to
protect him himself but we don't know
actually the new mid-season trailer
shows us Loki talking to someone using
this microphone but it's kind of hard to
tell who is under that helmet looks like
it's probably Victor timely but just
failing over and over again here we go
listen to me carefully hit the green
button it kind be a little
sticky now by the way many of you have
been asking since the magical barriers
of the TVA were dropped does that mean
the infinity stone paper weights in that
drawer are now usable no I don't think
so because it wasn't the anti-magic that
kept those from being usable it was the
fact that they were removed from their
home realities and Infinity Stones are
only supposed to work in their home
universes at least that's the way I look
at it the new midseason trailer includes
this new line from Loki from a moment
that seems like it was from episode 4
but we didn't actually see this line in
that episode Loki how much do you know
let's assume I don't know much but I'm a
fast learner and I'm a god well let's
start at the beginning so it seems like
Loki will time slip back to that episode
for a moment when he and Sylvie were in
the automat while the others were doing
their own thing and he's talking to
these others to try to talk them into
rethinking the plan that Obie had just
talked them through like Loki is
admitting that he doesn't know why the
plan failed but he's saying just give me
all the info and we're going to try this
again and again until it works kind of
like Bill Murray and Groundhog Day or
Doctor Strange in that episode of what
if they're just going to try this again
and again and then fail again and again
that actually might be why the
mid-season trailer also has a new angle
of Victor spaghettify but from behind
this time but part of Loki's time
slipping Journey will be apparently a
kind of recruiting mission to locate
variants of all of his friends before
those timelines spaghettify like we will
see Loki in the halls of the TVA before
it spaghetti fies we see that in trailer
footage starting with a Chona monitor
Bay and then there's a close-up of a
screen as Miss minute says thank you for
your service also spaghettify now I
don't know if this connected but it
looks like Loki will push through the
doors of Ren slayer's office in fact he
could be going back to right before the
moment when she steps through the time
door in the season one finale looking
for free will so this would prevent her
teaming up with Miss minutes in 1868
Chicago to give young Victor timley that
handbook but we will see Sylvie in a
record store of some kind as her room a
spinning record and her TV set all
spaghettify actually the very first
promo we got for season 2 was back in a
Hulu promo last December that showed
Silvie listening to music with that
monkey toy behind her this toy might be
important because we do see this toy in
the closing credits imagery of every
episode of season 2 Loki will meet up
with Sylvie in a bar with a pool table
and a jukebox where they have this
exchange what is it that you really want
I want to save my friends Loki will also
time slip back to Mobius origin as a jet
ski salesman of a piranha Powersports
other promo trailers show Owen in a
photo shoot wearing a teal piranha Power
Sports vest meaning that he works as a
Salesman at this location and in this
photo shoot he is riding a jet ski we
actually see a wide frame in a rectangle
and a very brief shot in another part of
the trailer actually the mid-season
trailer includes This Moment In which
Loki tells jet Sky salesman Mobius the
TVA is gone I think you mean ATV and no
we got in two of them last week so you
know what bad habits have a bad habit of
sticking around fighting them is hard
but trans forming something like Doom
scrolling from a bad habit to a good one
is easy thanks to fume fume makes it
possible to replace your bad habits with
good ones that you are free to enjoy
it's an Innovative award- nominated
device with no electronics no vapor and
no harmful chemicals fume is completely
natural and it uses all natural
ingredients to give you a burst of
delicious flavored air and fume is super
fidgety which is helpful for
de-stressing while you break your old
habit each device has an adjustable
airflow dial and it's designed with
movable parts and magnets using fume
just gives you a nice moment just for
yourself crisp mint makes my brain think
I'm sitting on a porch sipping a julip
and maple pepper gives me a strong
weakened brunch Vibe even if I'm just
waiting to cross the street and working
moments like that into your routine is a
good habit stopping is all something we
put off because it's hard but switching
to fume is easy enjoyable and even fun
fume has served over 150,000 customers
and has thousands of success stories and
there's no reason you can't be one of
them join fume and accelerating
Humanity's breakup from destructive
Habits by picking up the journey pack
today head to trif nume.com and use code
new rockstars to save 10% off when you
get the journey pack today that's TR
fm.com and use code new rockstars to
save an additional 10% off your order
today we also know that Loki and Mobius
are going to visit some residential
neighborhood that's lined with trees do
I need to play it the whole thing with
my hands on my hips where did this come
from actually the mid-season trailer
confirms this is Mobius is home
neighborhood we see his house where's
dragging the cans for the garbage and
the recycling actually based on those
small bikes the basketball hoop Mobius
has kids and apparently one of them
snuck out the night before there is a
rope made from bed sheets hanging from
the upstairs window but perhaps the most
important origin will be that of AA
Boris here's where things get
interesting because we see OB in normal
close suggesting that he was at one
point taken from regular old sacret
timeline history or some timelines
history this location actually kind of
looks like a University Library we see
equations on a chalkboard reminding us
of the equations on chalkboard and he
remains Citadel office we also see all
these node-based models like I wonder if
ob's background was in Academia but also
this could be the true origin of the TVA
cuz look closely at these tall shelves
of books in this location although the
lighting is different these walls have
the same curved slopes and high ceiling
as the TVA RNA Department room it is
either the same set that the production
just repurposed for a different set or
literally within the show it is the same
location and this is where it all began
with ob we are seeing the Bedrock of the
TVA but another trailer shot shows the
same location and apparently before too
long this room will also spaghettify and
Loki will time slip out of it this
mid-season trailer shows us various new
angles of this location with Loki one
point flanked by B15 and Sylvie but then
at the end of the trailer you can see
Loki in the middle seated and then Obi
casy B15 and Mobius and none of them are
in their TVA uniforms but rather what
they were wearing when Loki recruited
them like you can see Casey there
wearing what looks like a prisoner
jumpsuit and I have to point out this
room while destined to be become the RNA
Department I believe with those two fans
on the back wall also resembles he who
remains Citadel office with those two
smaller spiral Windows headwriter Eric
Martin teased a secret rule that he
applied to all of these episodes that he
couldn't say yet in that interview
because it would spoil these next
episodes but I think that rule is time
is a flat circle and everything we have
been seeing is tied together in a
self-justified knot so OB is looking
more and more like the original he
remains and the Citadel I think was
based on his original office it just
seems like the Kang variant he remains
took it over and made everything his own
we're also going to see b15s origin
where she is apparently a physician of
some kind we see her in a white lab coat
as a chaotic time door glitches around
behind her as if the TVA it's coming
from is melting down behind the scenes
footage shows all of these characters
with B15 in her hospital scrubs in that
same early RNA Department room with one
of ob's models on the coffee table there
but here the lighting makes it look more
like the RNA Department era and the
final Sprint of looki season 2 will also
be an emotional gut punch that circles
back to season one moment for example we
will see Loki back in time theater
number two back in the prisoner jumpsuit
the collar back around his neck
apparently revisiting Mobius is initial
interrogation from that first episode of
the series in these shots Loki shakes
Mobius his hand which didn't happen
before and he asks how do you choose who
lives and who dies but then we see
someone or something maybe movus
spaghettify in front of Loki as he cries
we are also pretty sure that Loki will
revisit the Citadel but not the ruins of
the Citadel that we saw in season 2
episodes 3 and 4 but The Citadel before
Sylvie stabbed he remains in season 1
behind the scene shots show Tom Heston
in this location specifically in
production for season 2 not old season 1
behind the scenes footage in all of
these shots The Citadel is still intact
and a fire Roars in the Hearth which it
did not before so apparently Loki is
going to time slip back to that critical
moment maybe to stop Sylvie from ever
stabbing he remains to begin with like
is Loki going to have to stab Silvia in
the back confirming her mistrust and her
pessimistic interpretation of that love
is a dagger quote confirming it all to
be true now a few more unseen trailer
shots that are left over we are going to
see Ren Slayer in the void facing elith
this is going to pick up with RN Slayer
after Brad who was enchanted by silie
pruned her in episode 4 we'll also see
Casey in some dark industrial basement
leading to other figures actually the
new mid-season trailer shows us an
exterior shot of this location and it
looks like a prison a windowless
concrete box with tunnels and a guard
Tower with a search light you can
actually see Casey emerging from that
hatch at top the Box could Casey have
come from a dystopian Days of Future
Past future that maybe was dominated by
one of the worst kangs his escaping
might have been what the TVA called his
Nexus moment that justified him being
taken as a variant and we keep staying
this one quick odd shot of Loki or Tom
hson just smiling at the camera I'm not
really sure what the context is for that
one okay that covers everything left
over that in some combination we will be
episodes five and six I can't wait to
see how this all fits together in this
final stretch and again I love this OB
inspired shirt so please support us by
grabbing one at nerd rot. shop and
please subscribe to all three channels
in the new Rockstar Network this channel
new rockstars the break room and the
Deep dive you can follow me at eaos
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
bye